cette économie que certain-es si
virtuelle la parole est à monsieur alain
suguenot
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
vous arrivez à la fin de cette mandature
le président de la république a renoncé
depuis longtemps déjà vous êtes donc le
seul à assumer le bilan de ses cinq
années
les trois candidats socialistes ou
assimilés l'élection présidentielle
dénoncent eux allègrement les échecs de
cette politique échec économique le
chômage n'a pas baissé bien au contraire
malgré les plans de formation malgré
quelques artifices de présentation échec
sur le plan de la croissance échec pour
notre balance commerciale
échec sur le plan de la dette qu'il va
falloir rembourser avec des taux
d'intérêt qui remonte dangereusement
pour la france échec pour le pouvoir
d'achat des ménages qui ne cesse de
baisser avec au surplus la menace d'une
inflation qui remonte allègrement échec
diplomatique
la voix de la france n'est plus audible
on l'a vu dans la partie de ping pong se
livrent messieurs trump et poutine ont
le vrai que notre partenaire allemand on
l'a vu en syrie échec institutionnels
monsieur le premier ministre la
polémique d'aujourd'hui met gravement en
cause d'indépendance du pouvoir
législatif et donc de l'état de droit
qui est mort aussi avec notre dame des
landes je n'évoque même plus
l'indépendance de la justice
mais le plus gros échec est sans doute
celui d'unité nationale je veux parler
de nos territoires
la france des territoires est à l'agonie
les réformes engagées depuis cinq ans
n'ont pas été sollicités par nos
compatriotes
la baisse des dotations la réforme des
rythmes scolaires ont ruiné les
collectivités locales aient augmenté de
fait la fiscalité les nouveaux
découpages cantonaux et intercommunaux
imposé sans concertation ont contribué à
éloigner le citoyen des pouvoirs de
décision monsieur le premier ministre
l'agriculture française n'a jamais subit
une crise aussi grave qu'en 2016 alors
qu'aucune solution d'avenir de lui était
proposé la couverture internet à nouveau
promis hier à l'horizon 2022 était la
grande carence de cette mandature
et personne ne croit à cette nouvelle
échéance je prie ministre il manque à la
france une vraie volonté une vraie
politique d'aménagement des territoires
ruraux
alors que vous allez attendre bientôt le
troisième âge la civilisation c'est à
dire après l'âge de pierre l'âge du
bronze
l'âge de la retraite avez vous à cette
échéance un regret et pourquoi pas une
idée dont les candidats quel qu'il soit
pourrait s'inspirer pour sauver enfin la
ruralité
la parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre bernard cazeneuve votre
question monsieur le député est une
véritable oeuvre d'art
parce que arrivés en deux minutes a
évoqué autant de sujets entremêlées les
uns dans les autres
sans qu'on comprenne vraiment vous
voulez en venir était un exercice
vraiment de très haute voltige
rhétorique et parlementaires auxquels
malgré tout je vais essayer de répondre
le premier point sur lequel je voudrais
vous répondre
c'est sur la situation de l'économie
j'ai essayé de le faire tout à l'heure
même si le temps nous est toujours
compté pour aller au fond des choses
en évoquant la situation budgétaire mais
je pourrais parler de la situation des
entreprises que vous avez évoqué lorsque
nous sommes arrivés en situation de
responsabilité
les marges des entreprises étaient
totalement effondré la compétitivité de
nos entreprises avaient été continûment
dégradé nous avions perdu 100 et il vous
plaît on est quoi industriels pour avons
nous fait nous avons mis en place
effectivement contrairement à ce que
vous avez dit dans votre question un
dispositif d'allégement des charges des
entreprises à travers le pacte de
responsabilité qui a permis de consentir
pour les entreprises 40 milliards
d'effort qui auront conduit le
gouvernement à créer les conditions
d'une restauration de deux points
démarches des entreprises ce qui nous
permet aujourd'hui d'être dans une
situation qui est meilleure que celle
qui existait avant la crise de 2008 pour
les entreprises et c'est parce que nous
avons fait cela monsieur le député que
l'investissement industriel est reparti
et atteint aujourd'hui 3,4 pour cent
là où il était négatif lorsque vous
étiez en situation de responsabilité
c'est parce que nous avons mené cette
action qu'en 2016 le chômage a reculé de
cent sept mille personnes et que le
chômage des jeunes est inférieure
aujourd'hui à ce qu'il était pendant le
quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy
mais cela bien entendu vous ne l'évoqué
pas parce que vous faites campagne avec
une idée et une seule s'est abaissée
l'image de notre pays continûment aux
yeux du monde pour des raisons
politiciennes
en essayant de nier les efforts qui ont
été faits continûment par ce
gouvernement
vous parlez des milieux ruraux vous
parlez de l'administration et des
services publics en milieu rural
mais me permettez moi de vous donnez là
aussi des chiffres pendant le
quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy par
l'effet de la révision générale des
politiques publiques vous aurez
supprimés dans les seules préfecture
2700 emplois quand on sait qu'il y a en
moyenne dans chaque préfecture 280
emplois c'est l'équivalent de 13
préfecture que vous aurez supprimés
pendant cinq ans ce qui signifie des
sous préfectures avec des services qui
ne sont plus en situation de répondre
aux demandes des élus locaux et
d'accompagner les collectivités locales
dans leurs projets nous avons mis en
place une réforme préfecture nouvelle
génération qui par la mise en place de
plates formes de titres aura conduit
notre pays à créer les conditions d'un
rehaussement de l'administration
préfectorale et graz à cette réforme
nous sommes aujourd'hui en situation de
recréer 750 emplois dans les préfectures
et les sous-préfectures ce dont vous ne
faites jamais état dans vos questions
tout simplement parce que vous êtes sur
tous les sujets dans
l'instrumentalisation de la peur et dans
la falsification des faits comme si vous
aussi vous aviez décidé de mener une
campagne en faisant une campagne n'ayant
les faits et la réalité enfin pour ce
qui concerne les services en milieu
rural ce que nous avons fait sur la detr
ce que nous avons fait avec les maisons
de santé
de service public nous conduit
aujourd'hui à ouvrir dans tous les
territoires des services publics qui
n'existaient pas croyez moi au moment du
bilan au moment de regarder la situation
en face les français seront en situation
de faire la différence entre ce que vous
avez fait et ce que nous faisons entre
vos mensonges et notre discours de
vérité